i unfortunately need to again remind our
friends in the audience and i you know
my friends on the other side of the
aisle my friends on my side of the i
don't care not even people not even on
an aisle or underneath it or whatever
presidents can do very little to control
gas prices and uh donald trump has put
out another one of these febrile screeds
although this one is just a single line
statement
talking about gas prices statement by
donald j trump
breaking news highest gas prices in
history
do you miss me yet
and donald trump wants to continue
tricking
his followers who don't know any better
and some of my followers also don't know
any better uh into thinking that the
high gas prices we are seeing are joe
biden's fault now there's a bunch of
different things that you have to
consider when such a statement is made
and hopefully many of you understand
what they are the first part is
is it even true that we are seeing the
highest gas prices in history and the
answer is yes we are
the answer is yes we are now
it's not inflation adjusted if you
wanted to do inflation adjustment they
are probably not the highest gas prices
in history but nominally speaking
we do have the highest gas prices in
history right now
how high are they going to go
you know economic predictions are
usually worth what we pay for them which
is nothing but
people are talking about 520 which would
be about would be about an additional
dollar per gallon or so from where we
are right now but the second question to
be asked
is is this happening only in the united
states or is it happening around the
world if it's happening only in the
united states we would then be able to
say is it the fault of the president
if it's happening around the world then
we would have to question whether it's
really joe biden's fault that gas prices
are up and of course when you look
around the world you see that gas prices
are up everywhere energy prices are
generally up because of what's going on
in uh in ukraine the russian invasion of
ukraine and the sanctions that have been
placed on russian oil which is refined
into gasoline
as well as on
uh natural gas coming from russia so
that's the situation it's not just in
the u.s
and it's not thanks to biden but i want
to talk about what presidents can do
that impacts gas prices i want to
mention
please this is a perfect time to do it
this video is sponsored by policy genius
if you have someone that relies on your
income could be children could be your
business partner
you might want to look at life insurance
and when you sign up for life insurance
it can be a big feeling of relief
knowing people you care about are
covered it's a lot simpler and more
affordable than many people think
especially when you use policy genius
you just click the link in the
description
policygenius.com david pakman show
answer a few questions very quickly
you'll be comparing personalized quotes
from top companies to find the lowest
price policy geniuses free to use they
take care of all the paperwork
they do not sell your information you
might have life insurance you might not
either way you lose nothing by taking
just a few seconds on policy genius to
see if you can get better coverage
for a better price you could say 50 or
more on life insurance comparing quotes
on policy genius go to
policygenius.com david pakman show and
get your life insurance quotes see how
much you could save
how can american presidents impact uh
gasoline prices okay three ways number
one if an american president declares
war on an oil producing country
prices are going to go up that's a
direct way that an american president
can impact oil prices look at the first
gulf war
in the early 1990s that's one way
uh number two
the american president can change
gasoline taxes if you raise gasoline
taxes the price of gas goes up if you
lower gasoline taxes the price of gas
goes down that's the second way an
american president can change the price
of gas and number three
the american president can choose to
release crude oil from what's called the
strategic petroleum reserve the spr
when you release oil from the spr
in the short term
it will sometimes drop oil in there for
gas prices it's not a lot depending on
where you look it could be 12 cents it
could be 18 cents per gallon
uh now
if the
driver of the higher prices isn't
actually a shortage of oil
releasing oil from the spr it can end up
being pretty futile so this is a global
situation
and i understand
that if gas goes from three to five
dollars a gallon not only does that
affect
people who commute to work it also
affects the cost of stuff because the
trucking that moves it around the
country is going to cost more if you use
oil to heat your home that's going to be
affected there is no question that it is
hugely impactful
it's just not joe biden's fault and
people very quickly lose credibility
when they say it is people putting these
stickers of biden saying i did that on
on gas pumps
it's silly you you're not a serious
person if that's what you're saying the
other aspect to this is
gas is much cheaper in the u.s than in
europe
it has been for a very long time
and part of that is that europe taxes
gas much more accurately when it comes
to the the total impact of a gallon of
gas
from an environment standpoint and fully
the u.s has not taxed gas accurately so
even when gas goes up it's still
underrepresenting the real cost of a
gallon of gas which should make us think
hey we should really be moving to
renewables and there is
not nearly enough being done to push us
in that direction but come on guys it's
not biden's fault that gas prices are up